one of my favorite people on planet
earth I love this man and I I don't get
a chance to work with him enough anymore
on the National Football League Network
he's on NFL gameday prime he's on 21st
and prime he's on NFL Network Super Bowl
prime he is primetime himself that prime
theme there they're just why not your
it's official I miss you too yeah well
I'm glad you see you here on the show
yes I used to know you when you didn't
have what's going on I didn't have hair
what's come over you
now you do you think I should do this do
you think I should adore what I do I do
it rich it will bring you back like no
but but where work but where am I now
though when you say bring me back not
really I'm happy happy like you know
what I mean like I'm happy with my head
zoom in on it I'm happy with my head
right now I'm happy with life my hats
have been cutting down they were up to
five days a week now I'm at two days a
week now because I'm feeling good about
prime right now I look at myself more
social media is taking at least nine
years off of my life nine years yes
she's like a young prime right now
picture of me and my profile doll today
I don't know if it was one of my sons of
me you know
you know Suze you know my wife she's
like seeing you on the air and she goes
huh she's like what is that deal and I'm
like yeah that's deal you know she's
really saying she's really seems like a
guy you know if your girl starts to pick
up a little weight you really can't say
it you just you know like hey you want
to work out a baby not not true but we
should work you know you can't say it so
she's like is that the idea and she's
just waiting for you to jump in there
it's like double dutch and you just send
that
she's doing the ropes and she just keep
looking oh you come home boom jump in
there you can do this work with on the
outsides this is your expert opinion has
okay so you have a lot of uh but if
donor hair they call it donor hair but
it but wouldn't it just be jarring for
people to see me women do it every day
they get extensions weave lace rush you
explain it to the white Olin ladies
brunch and all that you just gotta just
go for it you're brave rich you don't
care what people think what I have to
take like two weeks off no come on how
many days do have to be out of the
church they have fashionable heads that
I can hook that up rich you don't have
to be down any down to know what's by
the way this is one of my of the million
Dion stories I could tell of working
with you okay you remember you took me
hat shopping in Chicago when it was
freezing yeah and you're like take to
get that I put a fedora on like like the
one that Bella check you look good
though but you didn't have the nerve
nerve to keep wearing a fedora up on the
show like I have like okay they know
what's going on you tell them this is
what's going on I just have a rainy day
we're like three days five days and
you're back you're back rich should I do
it do it rich don't do it
rich yeah you should do it alright Deion
Sanders here on the Rich Eisen show who
wins this game prom what do you got for
me I never bet against a man named Brady
not that I'm a betting man because I'm
too cheap and I'm not involved so I
don't put my money unless I'm involved
right I would never pick against a man
named Brady for various reasons mm-hmm
it's gonna be a good game I feel but I
just can't do that
in a game of this magnitude multitude
anybody that you've ever been around and
any sport that
that he reminds you of with that sort of
gumption oh now can't better you cannot
even Jordan not even Michael Jordan's on
a whole new level but we gotta stop that
okay Jordan even more than break Jordan
is a hero is like when you raise the
flag Jordan is on the flag that's our
flag
Jordan is our fight as an athlete Jordan
is our flag okay
LeBron is close Jordan is our flag
so LeBron is close is closer to Jordan
and Brady is - Jordan no no Brady it may
be the next guy but he's still playing
you can't give them all their do unto
their stuff today stop playing it's hard
to talk about somebody alive you know we
do these these stories on these these
people because they're dead you know we
need to do it when they're alive they
give them their love when they're alive
we appreciate it when they're alive
right and it's hard to really fully
appreciate somebody when they're still
playing mm-hmm so you know I mean
he's won five he's been this is his
eighth super unbelievable first of all
craft Belichick and Brady it'll never be
done again that's the best three I mean
you're talking about that the amigos
amigos rep these three of those you know
the three stooges
these are the biggest three ever and
they're gonna go down in history like
The Three Stooges or the mingoes right
now do you think crafts should be in the
Hall of Fame no I know right now okay
right arguably the best owner craft
without a doubt the best head coach hmm
arguably with maybe one or two arguments
the best quarterback of all time
well you don't hold on you think there's
still an argument that Brady's the best
quarterback of all time yes why because
it will always be because generations
are different mmm generations would say
okay you take him and put him in the
generation in an 80s in the 90s would he
be that guy that's what generations do
mm-hmm
I don't do that but it would be an
argument well who would it be
Montana Brad but look Montana Marino you
know but they didn't play till they're
40 I mean look what he's doing at age 40
Deon I know but when you got the best
Dern head coach that ever played the
game and the best ownership it's hard
didn't or your offense and defensive
coordinators are up for head coaching
job baby that's melodies from heaven
whoo
who is the best coach you ever had
that's a good one
Bobby Bowden was an unbelievable man
unbelievable man on and off the field on
my defensive back coach shoot Mickey
Andrews I had so many good coaches head
coaches that's a tough one man
yeah that's really a touch why I asked I
love Barry Switzer man Switzer Swiss is
my doll not just my homey man so it was
a good guy had cared you X him right now
about a guy to play for him in his 80s
or 90s he remembers that guy and the
family good guy great guy okay do you
ever do you have a poll question for him
yes what's the greatest NFL dynasty 60s
Packers 70 Steelers 80s Niners 90s
couple days think I am or this page town
oval 60s Packers I mean you see me heard
about them I don't think I remember
metric football said yeah that's when I
had hair I just told a story about that
you know I was playing in the hood of
one of my friend's house and a rat ran
across the set and I got grabbed my man
I took him out here I said can i play up
on in these positions a rat ran across
the field during the game did it buzz -
yes yes yes all right so outside of the
sixties Packers who does the best
dynasty youth football yeah or these
Patriots the 90s Cowboys are
unbelievable but it has to be the Brady
air man it's the Brady era you can't get
no better than that Manny is a regular
season game the Super Bowl is a regular
season game for New England look all I
know is this is that when the NFL
Network started aren't we were 11 weeks
old when we went to our first Super Bowl
and the Patriots beat an NFC South
champion team in Houston and then next
year beat the Eagles well to go
back-to-back for three or four year old
Eagles and they're about to do it again
potentially as the winning in Houston
against an NFC South winner and now that
can try and go back-to-back and three
out of four with unbelievable against
the same team and the only constant is
that quarterback that owner and that
coach that's the best I can't believe
him by the way those two Super Bowls
those were those were BP before
for prey on the field Network alecky VP
now we're an AP in AP oh my gosh are we
ever NFL gameday prime after Super Bowl
50 - yep okay are you part of our eight
and half hours in the moon oh I'm not
manipulate me in the morning and keep me
there and hold me hostage there all day
why are you in your pajamas with the
foot at the bottom of you know no TV
you'll be in your footage I'll be in my
thighs should be all your part come on
you got no right come on no no it's not
fair cuz I'm gonna be tired you you're
done by what time 6:00 right you're out
of their place I'm on the Eric it
whatever 7 the morning out here
I'll be off there for 8 and 1/2 hours
yeah that's up to your agent right at
Deion Sanders you are the best thank you
you are the absolute best I love the del
to fully Instagram look by the way thank
you
come on all those sweaty selfies you
like yeah I mean look and you like you
like my Instagram that I did when I ran
on vacation and I did your your your you
where yah where I'm just twirling around
it around and I got busy we are three
and out as they say in the NFL business
I mean you have the matches on her back
which is just bragging heap around here
man right when work was over imagine if
I get the hair Oh Billy Blanks you're
Billy blink you're a tomb are you Billy
Blanks oh I don't know what you're
joking Billy blames me Wow
fifteen yards we're back with Tony Dungy
still they come here on the show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience